I ended up moving to Chicago and I was
interviewed with that agencies and they
said where are you the suit are you the
creative and these were the heydays the
Mad Men years in advertising and they
said well I can do both i had worked at
a small ad agency in ann arbor and i
said i met with clients i wrote ads i
designed ads i can do it all they're
like no you can't not heard a big agency
you have to choose why I ended up
getting a job with a magazine this
little society magazine in Chicago it
was a pretty horrible magazine but it
was a good experience because was a tiny
magazine and I got to do everything from
lay out the magazine to write stories
assigned an edit stories and after about
a year they wanted to close the magazine
they were losing their shirts and they
said we're going to close the magazine
what are you going to do and I said I'm
going to go into PR all these people
pitch me stories they've never read the
magazine there's got to be some
competence out there in this world so I
got a job with a little PR firm in
Chicago and fortunately they signed
anheuser-busch or Budweiser's the client
right after I got there and I spent
three years really getting an MBA in PR
and anheuser-busch is dying because
they're a great company a lot of
different brands a lot of different
celebrities and I learned how to do just
about everything and after my third year
at the rice lake snowmobile races when
was 25 degrees below zero in Wisconsin I
said okay I've learned what I'm learning
here and I wanted a bigger arena and I
went to work for a burson-marsteller the
international PR firm and I was there
about three years in Chicago and when
cold November day more than 20 years ago
they said would you like to move to LA
and I said oh yeah I'm out of here and
burson-marsteller is a great company but
la is a very entrepreneurial market it's
a very relationship market it's not like
people go oh you work for
burson-marsteller for the most part they
didn't even know who burson-marsteller
was necessarily so in 89 I started my
own firm in the back of my house and I
grew that to a company called Bragman
I'm in caffarelli which today is the
largest entertainment PR firm in the
world
old I sold the company in 2001 took some
time off and in 2005 i started my
current company 15 minutes which does a
lot of things my other company does but
in a very boutique format i have two
offices about 20 people and we represent
celebrities corporations the business of
hollywood a lot of crisis a lot of media
training very eclectic mix of clients in
that time I taught PR for six years at
USC so I learned everybody always said
PRS too esoteric it's hard to teach well
I had to learn that discipline I had to
learn how to explain what I do this
esoteric thing and in the course of that
it really made me want to write a book
and that was the German where's my
fifteen minutes
you